Why does that bearded fellow who plays Charles
Goodnight on "1883" look like someone we've
seen before?
And what does he have to do with the show
behind the scenes?
Keep watching for the answer.
Even people only vaguely aware of shows like
"Yellowstone" and "1883" probably know Taylor
Sheridan has something to do with the massively
successful franchise at the heart of the Paramount
Network.
And he does.
He's the creator.
"Yellowstone," the first TV series Sheridan
has created, is an enduring hit, spawning
multiple spinoffs, including: "1883," the
series that tells the story of the first Duttons
in Montana; "6666," an upcoming series set
at the real-life Four Sixes ranch in Texas;
and "1932," about the Duttons' difficulties
during the Great Depression.
Sheridan is also the creator of "Mayor of
Kingstown," a Paramount+ series starring Jeremy
Renner, and a slew of other upcoming originals,
including "Tulsa King," starring Sylvester
Stallone; "Lioness," starring Zoe Saldana;
"Land Man," starring Billy Bob Thornton; and
"Bass Reeves," starring David Oyelowo.
While Sheridan is arguably best known for
his behind-the-scenes work on these series,
his career in Hollywood goes back much further
than the launch of "Yellowstone" in 2018.
Before Sheridan made a name for himself as
a writer, he primarily worked as an actor,
and he's been in some pretty recognizable
roles.
In recent years, Sheridan has focused on writing,
but he's also made a handful of appearances
on his own projects, including a brief role
in 2016's "Hell or High Water" and an appearance
in "1883" as Charles Goodnight, a real-life
historical figure.
"When you bite off more than you can chew,
you sure bite big."
Well before he led the "Yellowstone" franchise,
Sheridan appeared as Deputy Chief David Hale
on a total of 21 episodes of FX's hit series
"Sons of Anarchy."
He was an integral part of the early series,
appearing in all but four episodes of the
first two seasons.
Throughout the first season, Hale operates
as one of the last honest officers in Charming.
Hale hates SAMCRO's criminal enterprise, so
he initially pursues the group in a fashion
decidedly different from that of his fellow
law enforcement officers, most of whom have
essentially learned to live with the biker
gang's actions.
"You make a deal with the devil to keep the
peace.
But look at this.
Look at what we let happen."
In Season 2, Hale begins to see the wisdom
in working with the group and opts to form
an alliance of sorts with Charlie Hunnam's
Jax Teller.
Sadly, their alliance is relatively short-lived.
In the Season 3 premiere, Hale is killed in
a drive-by shooting at a funeral.
In the years since his exit from the acclaimed
FX series, Sheridan has spoken rather bluntly
about his decision to leave the show.
In a wide-ranging interview with Deadline
in 2021, Sheridan admitted that he was troubled
with a number of things on "Sons of Anarchy,"
including his pay.
However, even more troubling to Sheridan was
the way that he was viewed as a lower-level
team member on the production.
He said,
"It wasn't so much over money.
It was so much more that that's how the business
saw me."
Sheridan's departure motivated him to pick
up writing again, which would lead to big
things.
Sheridan isn't exactly shy about including
himself as an on-screen presence in the series
that he leads.
Sheridan made his first appearance on "Yellowstone"
in Season 1's "Coming Home" as Travis Wheatley,
a role which he has reprised a number of times
since.
A horse trader, Travis is a through-and-through
cowboy, known for his no-nonsense attitude
and expert riding abilities.
While Sheridan only appeared in a single episode
of Season 1, he returned as Travis for two
more episodes in Season 2.
He opted to sit out Season 3, but made up
for his lack of screen time by appearing in
five different episodes during Season 4.
As a favor to Kevin Costner's John Dutton,
Travis gives Jefferson White's Jimmy Hurdstrom
a ride to the "6666" ranch in Texas, the cowboy's
home state.
"That's all cowboyin' is, all right?
It's you and a horse, doin' a job, tryin'
like hell to no let the other down."
We think it's safe to say that Travis will
probably find another reason to visit Montana
in "Yellowstone" Season 5, too.
And, while not much is known about the "6666"
spinoff yet, it also seems like a safe bet
that any "Yellowstone" series is bound to
feature Sheridan in some role.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "Yellowstone"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.